Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here is a caller trying to understand what does
it mean? I haven't had fast food in 20 years.
Speaker 7: Okay. David Torres from Vegas.
Watching your live coverage of this,
Herschel Walker, Raphael Warnock debate. Yes.
You mentioned something about not having any fast
food and 25 years. Does that mean that? You only
eat home prepared meals. I was just wondering.
Speaker 1: No, no. By no means. When
I say fast food, I'm talking about
McDonald's, Wendy's, Burger King, Taco Bell.
Some people say Taco Bell, those types of
places. I haven't been to those types of places,
with the one exception of the KFC incident, which
I've described before on live. I have not been
to any of those places Subway for more than 20
years. Normal restaurants I go to all the time,
but normal restaurants are not fast food, but
kind of like the industrial chain restaurants.
I have not gone to. That's what I meant. Okay.
We have a great bonus show for you today. We're
going to talk about the latest Elon Musk U-turn on
funding StarLink in Ukraine. Really weird. Again,
what's going on? California drivers can now sport
digital license plates on their cars. Oh, boy.
What does this mean? And we will also talk about
this activist group that threw soup on a Van Gogh
painting. Do I like this as a protest tactic or
not? I think many of you in the audience probably
have a guess. All of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get instant access by signing
up at join Pacman dot com. Great bonus show for
you today. Otherwise we'll be back tomorrow.